Hi, Dr. C. Just had an ultrasound of my three months check-up after being moved from
its box bin for lumps and shrunken by 30% so far so good. My labs showed a few results
that need improvement, however, I sent those labs to you. I'm sorry, I've not looked at those.
Yeah, what can I do to increase these numbers? A collegeist will review labs at the
end of September 23rd and will advise the next steps hopefully, continuation of status quo.
Is it okay for me to start back on all my subs after a four month break as a protocol?
Honestly, I think I would do another cheap swap test before you start back on everything.
Short of that, I mean, certainly you could start back on things and maybe you start with a lower
goal, sit and tighten up, or maybe do another cheap swap test in the middle of it.
And if you want me to go over those labs with you, speak in a private I did not know that your labs,